hello everyone welcome to the session on
proactive network operations using
network intelligence center my name is
manusa cholasani i'm a product manager
with google cloud
uh in the cloud networking team and i
focus on our products related to
network performance monitoring
diagnostics
and i have with me here gargi
thank you manson hi everyone uh this is
gargi attu
i run engineering in cloud networking
and network intelligence center is one
of the initiatives my teams
are contributing to so i want to start
off with
uh sharing a little bit more about what
we heard from all of you
around the problem statements regarding
network operations monitoring
diagnostics
and the first thing we heard from all of
you is basically the lack of
comprehensive
single pane of glass view for anything
related to network troubleshooting and
monitoring
today you had to move between various
panes of glass
be it homegrown tools or on-prem tools
or various third-party cloud monitoring
tools and you had to stitch all that
information together
and what that led to was that at some
places you had to actually spend a lot
of time sometimes days to be able to
figure out
and investigate these issues and that
problem was even more complicated when
it came to your hybrid deployments
uh specifically troubleshooting on-prem
to uh cloud
another key point that we heard from you
was that you
did not have visibility into real-time
network performance metrics
one other point that came up from all of
you was that a lot of times
when you push out these configuration
changes continuously in your environment
it was very difficult to understand
what uh is the impact of
those configuration changes uh that you
push out to firewalls
routing uh load balancers etc and
that might again increase your time that
you take to investigate any issues that
would have been caused
because of these conflict changes uh so
overall
what we heard was you needed a single
kind of intelligent
platform that helps you monitor your
network
provide visibility and provide you our
diagnostics to be
to help you on a day-to-day operations
perspective so
we took all of that feedback and uh from
ground up we built the network
intelligence center
it's the comprehensive network
monitoring verification
and optimization platform offered by uh
google cloud
um and the focus again is to
uh offer you all the visibility and uh
reduce the time you take to be able to
troubleshoot
any network issue we starting off with
four modules which we will go through as
a part of this presentation
network topology performance dashboard
connectivity test
and firewall insights these start off
with providing you with the visibility
and monitoring of your network as well
as troubleshooting tools for diagnosing
any issues quickly
but this is just a start and there there
will be more modules that will
continue to introduce as part of network
intelligence center
as we move towards providing you with
further
insights and recommendations and
optimizations for your network
and i want to also quickly mention that
uh the network intelligence center is
actually part of
active assist which is a brand new
solution that's being offered by google
cloud
uh that focuses on reducing the
complexity of your overarching cloud
environment
by providing you with a variety of
intelligent and proactive features
uh we will uh towards the end of the
presentation we'll give you more details
around activision in other sessions that
you can get more information
on this as well so with that let's start
off with the first module
network topology network topology is a
visualization of your global gcp
deployment
it shows actual communications between
various networking nodes like compute
instances
to the public internet and also to
network services like load balancers
nat and uh etc and it also shows you all
of the associated
performance metrics for all of those
edges
so and all of these metrics as well as
the topology itself we are able to
capture and track over a period of time
over six
weeks so that you can actually see how
each of these evolved over a period of
time
and generate insights from that next
let's move to how
you can use network topology uh these
are some of the common use cases that we
saw
our customers using network topology for
the first one is network monitoring
uh so this is where customers kind of
made sure that the topology that they
viewed here within network intelligence
center was in line with what the intent
was
uh for by the network team as they were
deploying that infrastructure
uh and so that could mean things like
for example
if you have uh if you want all of your
uh compute instances to talk to the
public internet
through load balancers and not directly
that's something that you can very
easily check
using this uh product or you can very
quickly check if all of your say for
example
asia users are being served from the
closest region to them
or not the second use case is around
uh network troubleshooting so network
topology has a
very fast and quick filtering capability
where
in case for example you are
troubleshooting a specific network issue
related to
an instance or a load balancer you can
you can filter
for that specific instance and view all
of the
traffic as well as metrics associated
with that vm instant
very quickly as well as see what that
uh looked like at the point of time of
the incident because
because you're saving the topology
itself over a period of time
the third use case is uh architecture
optimization
uh so around architecture optimization
once the customers actually understand
what the architecture looks like they
can now very quickly
perform optimizations around cost or
performance say for example being able
to understand
what your traffic looks like between
various regions can help you uh
optimize the egress traffic the next one
is tracking workload migration
so as you're moving your resources onto
the cloud
topology provides you a very easy way to
understand
uh how your deployment is evolving what
are the performance metrics associated
so that accordingly you can tweak your
deployment architecture
to optimize for performance or cost or
availability
the fifth one is around compliance uh
checks and
uh audits export this topology to be
able to
submit this as part of your sock audits
without requiring any third party tools
this is a very quick capture of what
network topology looks like on the top
you have
countries which capture external clients
public internet
in the middle are load balancers which
you can click through to understand all
the load balancers you have deployed and
at the bottom are gcp regions where you
have your compute instance deployed
and you can drill down all the way to
the vm instance
all of these edges capture metrics and
you can click through to understand
exactly how those metrics evolved for
each of those
uh edges now let's move on to the next
uh product with the network intelligence
center called performance dashboard
a performance dashboard provides
real-time performance metrics like
latency and packet loss
for your uh project and for your set of
vms
so this reflects uh the customer's
actual experience within gcp
we look at all of the vm to vm
performance metrics and aggregate it to
a zone level to be able to understand
show you
what the inter zone
uh latency and packet loss looks like
for for your project in your environment
and uh so what that means is uh whenever
there is a
for example investigating an application
issue you can very quickly understand if
this is
a network level issue or not and make a
take a call based upon that
these metrics will be available over uh
the per project performance dashboard
which is now ga which is part of your
network intelligence center console it
will also be available as part of
our network topology as part of the
edges that we just saw
as well as as uh metrics are consumed
via cloud monitoring where you can set
up
alerts as per your requirements and use
cases
now i will move on to show the demo of
the performance dashboard
now let's get started with the demo so
the way to get to performance dashboard
is you go to your console uh
under networking you will find network
intelligence
and performance dashboard there you can
click through that performance dashboard
is a ga product so you should be able to
view this at your end
and what you see here is packet loss
and latency for your set of vms and your
specific project itself so it's your
experience of the network
and uh on this chart here you will see
uh the average packet loss across
all of your zone pairs where you have
vms deployed and
also the packet loss for the highest
loss zone pair
for any given sample so now if i want to
investigate further let's click through
and zoom in on this time frame
and uh see what's happening at
uh this specific time frame now when i
clicked on that
a two by two chart uh matrix shows up
and you'll see all of these zones are
basically the zones where you have your
vms deployed
and here i see that there's a specific
packet loss recorded between
asia east 1b and europe west 2c
now i can click through further here to
understand
what the for this specific zone pair
what the packet loss was over a period
of time
and this this metric is recorded over
six weeks so you can view
that over six weeks now i can
zoom in further here and understand that
this packet loss
was recorded uh at 9 41
and at 9 40 and 9 42
uh it was at zero so what this enables
you to uh
answer is whenever there is any
application related issue happening you
can go back here and understand if this
was related to a network issue or not
and also how long did it last
now going back here similarly you can
access latency information as well
and you have similar charts available
for latency
and also you can see median latency
across all of these on pairs where you
have your vms deployed at any point in
time
with that let's move back to
uh the rest of the presentation and the
other modules
with that next i want to also call out
the
live public google cloud inter-region
performance dashboard that we recently
launched
uh this shows uh interregion performance
metrics latency and throughput for all
of our
inter-region traffic uh using perfkit
benchmarker
perfect perfect benchmarker is an open
source
toolkit uh well provided by google
but it has hundred plus uh contributors
and the key thing to this is it utilizes
uh some of the common aspects of
performance testing like ping net perf
iperf
uh but what it does it is it automates a
lot of the process around testing so
it automates a process around uh
provisioning your vms setting up the vpc
setting up five wall rules as well as at
the end of the test
tearing the entire infrastructure and
this dashboard also provides
a tutorial into how exactly you can
reproduce any of these metrics uh this
is uh this is we're providing this to
you so that you can make calls around
where to deploy your uh resources so
that
uh you can optimize for performance
within google cloud and provide that
visibility
to make those decisions with that i will
hand it over to
gargi thank you mansa
um so the next module we will talk about
is called connectivity tests
so one of the biggest pain points that
we heard from customers during our
research and like mansa mentioned
uh was the lack of troubleshooting
capabilities
and when we did a survey of the
customers it turns out that
almost 75 percent of network failures
and performance issues are resulting
from
configuration errors and once these
network failures happen it is really
hard to
pinpoint and troubleshoot as to a root
cause as to where
the problem was happening and that
itself takes a long time and it
increases the outage period
so one of the biggest requests from
customers was that if you could just
tell us whether
the root cause of the failure is it
google or is it us
or is it the network that itself would
be a huge value add
the other problem was that it's very
hard to understand that when
any of your admins are making
configuration changes
what is going to be the impact of it
whether these are rock-solid config
changes or is something going to fail
so the what of the connectivity test is
uh
it's a tool to help you diagnose
connectivity issues
uh before you act can actually do it or
even after you are you have done it
saying these are the conflicts that have
changed and as a result
uh these are the failures uh between a
source or destination or to even
validate
that yes this is the flow that you were
expecting and it is doing it as you
expected
how do we do it so we don't actually run
a ping or a trace route so this is
complete static modeling of your network
using
uh your configuration uh files and your
routing information and so on
so uh here is an example of a
connectivity test
or you can have like source and desk
protocols or
protocol and ports uh either you can
specify
an ip address or as a source and
destination or you can have
vms a source vm and a desk vm or with
their respective ports which is optional
and
and also protocol field which is
optional uh and what we give to you
is a step-by-step visualization about
what path your packet would be taking
and what configurations it would be
hitting
uh so in this case it is starting from a
vm instance there is an egress firewall
that it hits
uh which it passes then there is a
static route lookup that happens
which it passes uh and uh then there is
a nat
lookup which is which is where it fails
that maybe there is a missing net rule
so here are a few examples of
connectivity tests
that we have shown like different paths
that it can take
uh the first one is uh it goes through
a firewall rule or it is successful and
if there is no reason
for the failure and it says the packet
is dropped it could also be that
it goes outside your im policy domain
that it allows you and you may want to
reach out to your super admin who has
the policies because of which you
between both of you you could understand
the reason uh
the second example is in this case it is
going through
a firewall rule uh and then it is
getting dropped
uh in the third example it is going
through um
it is going through a load balancer uh
and then it is getting dropped
and the fourth one is a successful
example that we have taken where it goes
through
a vpn tunnel uh and then it uh
comes in right and we show you the
different steps just like our trace
route would
except that in this case um a trace
route shows ip addresses versus here
you see all the steps of the
configurations that would be executed on
that packet right be it of
vpn tunnel beat a routing look up be it
a natural look up or a firewall rule
and in case of a nat and a fireball rule
failure or even
a success we would tell you exactly
which rule it hit
and why it was a success or a failure so
you could go back in real time and say
like oh
the survival rule is accidentally
blocking this packet and that's not what
i intended you go change that and then
you will see it immediately that
your packet flow is successful so let's
talk about the next module
uh this is called firewall insights so
one of the other
challenges that we heard from many of
you uh
is around firewalls and the management
of firewall groups
uh several people had like thousands and
thousands of firewall rules
and if they wanted to optimize it they
did not know where to start
because usually what we heard was there
is a series of admins some security
admin in the past must have created this
firewall rule and they went ahead to
a different role and new security admins
came on
and we said then how do you figure out
which rules are still active they said
oh
we do not delete firewall rules we just
add them
so that is that makes the firewall rules
very unmanageable and you don't even
know where to start
so as a result you end up with a massive
volume of eyeball rules
and sometimes there is over granting of
rules because you just
grant it at a higher level ip address
range even though you may only be
partially using some of it
uh there is also human error of course
and there is no way to figure out
unless there is an actual traffic uh
drop that
oh something bad had happened um
and then the other thing is like we
talked about outdated rules because
people are too afraid to change them
mainly going back to they don't know
what else could break
and what was the intention of this rule
for byte was created
so fibo insights took on all these
problems and we said okay let's tackle
that by applying intelligence to
the data that we have and the
configurations that we have
so one of the first things that we have
done is give you visibility into usage
metrics
uh of based on each firewall rule like
what has been the hit rate in the past x
number of days and so on
uh and you can see the hit count the
timestamp stamp
and you can export these this data is
exported to stackdriver where you can
set your own alerts the other part is
through
analysis and applying some symbolic
analysis on the config data
uh we are able to show you what is the
hierarchical relationship among
different rules
which rule is shadowing another rule
right like for example
there is a higher priority slash 16 rule
and then there are three lower priority
slash 24 rules which are obviously being
shadowed those
slash 16 is shadowing though or the
lower priority rules
and as a result you could easily get rid
of the
underlying three allow rules because you
have an
overarching uh allow rule that is shadow
that is
you know uh addressing this allow uh
functionality or desire so
that's a very simple example of
optimization but then there are complex
other more complex examples so we
analyze all of that and we show you the
shadowing and shadowed relationship
uh between the rules among the rules and
then
we as a result we allow you to
strengthen your firewall control
by even recommending to you um or
showing you insights on where some of
your security could be tightened
by showing you that these are the only
rules which are being
hit and so there are there's two ends of
the spectrum on one in the end of the
spectrum you are able to
optimize your firewall rules and on the
other end of the spectrum
you are able to strengthen your security
by making
uh the rules more specific um
and you could do both based on what your
desire is
now we'll go to the demo for fibo
insights
firewall insights provides you three
main things today
firstly it shows you the different
relationships among your firewall rules
the shadowing shadowed conflicting
relationships
secondly it shows you which of your deny
rules
have been hit and thirdly which of your
allowed rules have not been hit in the
last
60 days as we discussed
firewall rules can be added by different
people over time
causing new rules to be accidentally
overshadowed by existing rules
or vice versa without any automated
detection this is really hard to do
so for example if there is a vm1 in a 10
1
24 subnet uh which cannot reach vm 2
in a 10 slash 24 subnet when you
intended it to
uh the first thing you would do is run a
ping test so you go to vm1
and you can ping 10.202
and see what happens
the ping failed so let's see what could
be the root cause of this
so to troubleshoot you would go to vm 2
and view the network details
to see what are the configurations that
are applied on vm2
and you see oh there is a 10 one slash
16
deny 5 rule which is shadowing a 10 1
24 allow firewall rule naturally causing
your traffic to be
blocked and thus break there could be
multiple such instances
that are in your firewall rules and if
you have thousands of them
it's really hard to automatically detect
and find these conflicts
so firewall insights in network
intelligence center
provides you exactly that it gives you a
list of all your shadowed rules
in your firewall configs in your vpc and
which you can audit and figure out which
ones to clean and keep
or which ones to keep so a single rule
or a multiple rules can be blocked by
multiple
or a combination of other rules in this
case an allow rule to tcp
ports at443 are being blocked
by or shadowed by a deny firewall rule
naturally causing this breakage to
happen
so you may want to proactively uh audit
all the shadowed rules in your firewall
conflicts and
figure out which ones match your traffic
needs and intent and which ones don't
and you don't want to keep and clean
those up
the second powerful thing that fibo
insights provides
is a list of allow rules that have not
been hit in the last six weeks
so you could come here to view a full
list of these rules
so as you can see there are multiple
rules that have not been hit in the last
six weeks
and if you ordered these these could be
rules left over by past applications
where
someone forgot to clean them up so in
this case there is a web app one which
has
a five volt allow rule uh for a zero
slash zero
ip address and uh it's not been hit in
the last six weeks so naturally
web app one probably went away and this
got left over
as a vestige hole in your network so
reviewing these rules will help you
tighten your security boundaries the
third powerful function that's provided
to you is the deny rules with heads
now these could point to unintended
abnormal traffic behaviors it could even
be attacks
into your network and to figure out
where
these attacks are coming from you could
go to the firewall logs corresponding to
the firewall rules
and see where the source of the traffic
is
and especially when you have a large
abnormal behavior you may want to
look into that traffic source either
there is a mis-configuration or
there is an attack coming from those
sources
in summary 5v insights gives you four
powerful functions
firstly it gives you real-time
visibility into your firewall rules
utilization and stats
it secondly it automatically detects
overlapping and misconfigured firewall
rules
thirdly it helps you optimize your
firewall configs
by enabling you to delete any shadowing
shadowed
conflicting or unused firewall rules
that do not match your intent
and finally it helps you tighten your
security boundaries
by detecting any unused vestige rules
that may be creating holes in your
network through a combination of all
these
firewall insights thus helps you to
optimize
and maintain the right set of firewall
rules to protect your cloud deployments
so to wrap up uh we have launched the
network intelligence center which has
gone ga
uh it includes all the four modules that
uh mansa and i talked about today
on network topology and performance
dashboard uh connectivity test and
firewall insights so as you can see um
we are get taking an approach of
proactive
uh intelligence like proactively
monitoring and operating
your network or shortening the outages
that happen
in a network uh and as a result then you
come to
trust the gcp network intelligence a
little
more right we'll trust and basically
help you
manage your network better
so as next steps here are some related
sessions uh
there is a cloud and complex session um
that you should definitely attend it's
related
uh what's new in network security uh it
will talk to you about the overall
security
initiative from gcp and uh it will talk
about
firewalls or at an uber level and also
delve into
firewall insights and if you want to you
could reach out to us
at network intelligence center at
google.com
and follow our blog on product slash
networking
thank you